you
[Music]
so thank you everybody for coming
welcome so I'm very pleased to introduce
Kristoff p'tee he's been a frequent
visitor to our group and worked together
on Asajj new base crypto problems for
many years we're very pleased to have
him back he's been a research fellow at
Oxford University most recently and now
a lecturer at University of Birmingham
so thank you thanks Christian a great
pleasure to be here and thank you very
much for inviting me so you may have
heard of it there's something called
quantum computers and that will break
all our crypto today so you want to do
something about it and maybe you want to
find some problems that are not just
login factoring that we resist quantum
computers and one of the problems that
has been suggested recently is what
family of problem is what's called ISO
Gini problems so they were proposed
recently for well it wasn't yeah for
post quantum Krypton and in other
context the reason for that one reason
for that is that at the moment the best
classical and quantum algorithm still
require exponential time so that's good
one reason I like those program is is
because they're not just made for like
proving being able to prove the secure
of a crypto system but they actually
have some history so David called back
then in 1996 already studied some of
them so it does give some more
confidence than these the problem was
kind of build up for like proving your
crypto system and the problems are kind
of natural from a number theory point of
view if some of them is kind of natural
what will come to that but when you
given any teacher to ask questions such
as and amorphous in ring welcome to them
ok here's the outline given the
motivation hopefully I want to kind of
do an overview and and then go to some
recent results that will that maybe will
excite more people that know already
about the topic so I'll talk about the
different particles that exist in this
area I'll talk about
what sort of problems are hard and easy
or of what sort of problem are easy and
what sort of problem may be hard sit sit
and then I will go into this recent
result of mine okay all right so let's
start with isogen ease and cooktop rod
calls and I thought uni so that's that's
a PDF prime so up to isomorphism any
super singularity of can be define of SP
square and I so Jeannie is just more
from Montreal more person sending one
curve to another and preserving the
neutral element so it's a rational map
so you can write it as well if in by
stress coding you could write it in in
this way in in terms of coordinates of
easier you get the images of of 5x XY
here well just a bit of more
introduction the degree is its degree of
this guy or the degree of this guy and
some station will write easier be one
question by sorry will write easier
question divided by G equal to e1 or
when G is the kernel of of Phi okay
later more of context oh my hair already
okay so I so gene problems so all the
problems that we interested in in this
area I bought computing some eye surgeon
needs whatever this means okay or some
variants of this product for those
programs to be hard the eye surgeon is
must must have large degree so if the
degree is small you can do just doing
those research however the kind of
representation I show you here if the
degree is large that's just not
efficient
okay so we need some some kind of trick
to actually even just return the output
in some some efficient way so one such
trick is that if the degree is smooth
then you can write the i30 as a
composition of low degree education and
that makes the the representation
efficient okay in some protocols and
we'll come back to that
the attacker doesn't just get to curves
and has to compute an ISO Gini between
them but he also gets an additional
information and the last at the end of
the talk we see how this could
potentially affect the security all
right
well feel free to intuit for the
convention for more basic introduction
so over the algebraic closure the head
portion is just isomorphic to Z
electrons yellow and each of those and
their L plus 1 subgroups in there and
each of them correspond to to the kernel
of a degree Eliza G when I describe okay
so we can build this graph where every
vertex is Satya
a super singular curve or invariant and
you have an edge between two curves if
they're connected to some degree Li so
Jeannie okay so those graphs are very
cool they're undirected so for every
every I so genius let's call it zero
which goes in the opposite direction you
are so in super single case everything
is defined over P Square or can be
define diversity square the graphs are
known to be runnin around that
essentially means optimal expansion so
if you do a random walk you quickly
reach uniform distribution there and if
you thinking of the isogen problems that
are just computing either jinyu between
two curves in in terms of graphs this
would just mean computing path into the
scraps okay so maybe it's useful to have
this intuition to understand well well
what we're talking about right any
questions so far
okay let's go to the constructions then
a hash function at i we expect everybody
know everyone knows what it is
so you interested in collision
resistance famous resistance and second
preimage resistance first one meaning
you can't find two messages that hash to
the same value pretty much resistance
essentially means you cannot invert and
second preimage is something a bit in
between perhaps where you give them a
message and have to find a second
message hashing to the same value
there of course fundamental building
block encryptor used for integrity
authentication in cgi teacher and the
first protocol first construction based
on iso Janee in the super senior case
was christine / function so so this is a
super single ERISA aging graph right so
the vertices are just during variance as
Persinger inverse and the idea is that
you use split your messages you
messaging to bits
and each bit determines a step in the
graph so let's say you start here and
then if you beat this one you would go
there and it is really good there at
each end and so on its own remember the
graph is regular so so every vertex you
have well in this case you have three
vertices but you also don't want to make
backtrack because that would give it
your children collision right so the the
output of the hash function is just the
final vertex that you reach here so this
chair variant okay so if you want to
solve for the premature resistance
problem in this case well give Li what
it means is is that you're given two
curves and you want to find a path
between that right so you want to
compute an I so Janee in this case of
degree l2 something that connects this
curve in this curve another way to break
the function would be to find a loop
right because that would give you a
sequence of message that together go
back to the same message and then you
can maybe you can concatenate this
sequence of message with with this
message and then you get a collision as
well so this would be a nano morphism in
dear teacher saying okay so the function
is kind of nice you can t really
translate secure properties in terms of
as urgent problems you also have this
expansion property that means that
translate into the fact that as long as
the message is how long enough the the
output will be uniformly distributed
which is also something that you you
would like for a hash function okay all
right any questions so far on the key
exchange under sorry the hash function
no right a second protocol I want to
mention is is a key agreement so here
the goal is for Alice and Bob to agree
on some common shared key while only
exchanging public messages okay so it's
kind of for what for you it would be
achievable but but some for some origins
it's not intuitive that this is even
possible so Eva sees all the messages
that are public and and then at the end
of this conversation I send Bob has a
secret that should remain secret to to
Eve and of course there is a very
standard way of doing that it's called
the diffie-hellman protocol you choose a
psychic group to choose a generator for
this group and then Alice will just pick
a random a and San G to the a Bob does
the same thing random beastie to be then
I'll if they exist to the be ready to
the disc is G to the a B and Bob do
something similar and then they both
have G to the a B and if you believe
that this gridlock is hard and actually
diffie-hellman is hard then a decision
in the amendment is hard then you can
see all messages and cell is not able to
infer anything about the shared key
great
so very nice protocol based on either
genie was developed around those IDs so
here's what you do so pick a prime P and
two integers n a and B such that they
core prime to each other so GCD is one
pick a super single curve over FB square
then what does like the equivalent of
choosing a random is is in this case
it's choosing a cyclic group in DNA
torsion okay and then she computes the I
so Jeannie was Colonel is equal to the
psychic subgroup PA okay so she computes
the size o GN and the curve here and so
this gives a curve ei that she sends
about okay Bob does something similar
except that he works with envy so he
choose chooses a cyclops a group GD
within this and B torsion computes the
curve
EBE and sends EB to Alice okay and now
you want the shared key to be equal to e
0 question 2 by G a G be like the group
generated by those two okay so again we
write this as e because indeed by five G
of G a or F a question 2 by Phi a of G
be great except that what is then is
this and this so if you want to if say
both wants to compute the shared key but
those Phi D that it is no G a that's
that's a secret of Alex you know CB
buddy doesn't know Phi a again okay and
similarly for ali so so as such Alice
and Bob are not able to compute this
shared key so the key tricking in Java
the field prodigal was was to send any
additional information okay so what they
do is that well this defect it's a group
that that Alice chooses can be
represented as as the subgroup generated
by point of this form okay so if you
take da QA a basis for DNA torsion then
you can choose alpha and beta in not
both at least one co-prime to n a and
and this will be a cyclic subgroup of
orion a right so that defines this year
and then if Bob reveals Phi B of P a and
Phi D of Q in and and now this is public
information
I don't need only on the alpha and beta
are not public so if Bob reveals this
then Alice can actually compute the
image of of this group to Phi B okay so
that's the kind of trick that they use
thing it's very clever okay a couple of
additional comments for this to be so
this works but to be efficient you like
any to be smooth because then the
Diogenes can be represented as a
sequence of small degree hydrogenise
right so this is important and then you
have to work with n torsions here right
so you like this this enter
option to be also represented Belen an
efficient way new computer and there are
two ways to do that that I know this is
the way that Jarl and the CEO suggested
so if you take na dividing PP minus 1
then the the world torsion will be
define diversity square and that's great
ok because then you can you can
represent everything over IP square
another way to do that and I will come
back to it is to choose na a person's
number in the sense that if you write it
as a product of prime the largest perf
prime is small enough ok if you do this
then officially in a torsion you can
represent lem any element in torsion s
as a sequence of elements in the Li to
the e aí torsion and that makes an
efficient representation as well not a
sufficient price but but it would be put
in many times well any question on this
alright so here's the key exchange so
the blue information is known only to
Alice the red information is known to
Bob and this is the shared key right so
Alice chooses our our a and then about
sense this and from there
Alice can compute this so if I say
jelly-filled choose any dividing p minus
1 but they also chose ni equal to poor
small prime in fact two and three such
that this is as efficient as possible
but if you want it to be safer in my
opinion a priori
you would like to choose the other
variants with ni equal to P Square
roughly so the reason for that is that
was first of all in their parameter you
choose very special Prime's and that
encrypt lies a history of being a bad
idea and second of all the degree here
is kind of too small so if you think of
the two curves here in the graph they
kind of closer than two random curves
would be and that potentially could lead
to an attack and in fact the best
attacks are better in this case them for
generator
I search any problems so for those two
reasons
it could be a priori safer to use the
other variants where you choose ni to be
a product of small power of primes
okay any questions so far but of course
I mean this is more efficient or it's
expected to be more efficient all right
any question on the kicks change now
this is all familiar to you ID protocol
are proof of knowledge here the goal is
that somebody wants to prove knowledge
of a secret so the prover wants to prove
knowledge of some secret to very far
without revealing anything about the
secret that can be used for example in a
authentication protocol and the secure
requirements in for those protocols are
correctness soundness and image
correctness just means that if you know
the secret you should be able to prove
that you know the secret Sun s means
that if you don't know the secret you
shouldn't be able to prove that you know
the secret and the knowledge means that
nothing is geeked about a secret all
right and so typically those particles
are interactive and can be made non
interactive using some standard tricks
so his ears their suggestion you are the
secret the secret here is a nicer
journey between two curves easier anyone
and the protocol is interactive is Trier
and particle so prover will first
compute those hydrogenise here and that
that's like in the key exchange protocol
so this I so Jeannie would correspond to
this and like like in the key exchange
protocol really accepted the pictures
kind of lift a ton turn a little bit so
prover will commit with those two curves
the verifier will challenge the prover
with one bit
so either 0 or 1 if it's 0 the previous
winter with this this has a genie on
this side Virginie if B if B is 1 it has
to answer with this one right so this is
correct because obviously if you know
the secret you can compute this then
sound because if you
can answer to both challenges so in both
case when B is equal to zero and B equal
to 1 and means that you know those three
eyes are genies and from there you can
recover this one and this is zero
knowledge if you want to assume some
special adult harness assumption okay so
I want to come back come to that okay so
that's another protocol which is also
kind of cool and then well it's well
known in crypto that if you have key
exchange
Allah Allah deaf ear man then you can
derive a public key encryption Allah al
Gamal okay so so this can be done here
so you derive for a key encryption from
from the key exchange and that's kind of
an exercise for from a crypto background
and then we also interesting signatures
and it's also well known that if you
have an ID protocol you can derive a
signature out of it right this is called
the fie hme transform if you care about
post quantum Security's you guess you
would in this area then there's an
alternative called the enroute transform
which does a job alright so in this
paper that's available in ePrint what we
do is Stephen Galbraith and the student
notes for this is building an
alternative protocol that has kind of
stronger security guarantees than than
this signature and then then this ID
protocol and we divide the signature
scheme from there anyway any questions
so far so that's about all in terms of
protocols there are few protocols
desires were suggested that like weird
versions of signatures the teacher but I
think those are the most interesting
ones okay so let's go to the math the
problems okay that's an easy problem so
if you're given a kernel computing the
i30 mean it's easy ish let's see
why so given this Colonel there's
something called values formula it's
actually very explicit formula that
gives you a formula for the four for the
isogenic even given the chronology right
so here XP just means the be the
x-coordinate of the point P and of
course xpeke askew unites each R so
that's fine that's an explicit formula
but as you you can see the efficiency
here's at least all of size of G right
so so if G is big this is not going to
be efficient and remember encrypter we
want you to be big we want the degree to
be big okay well if these composites as
I already mentioned you can you can kind
of use a Chinese remainder theorem kind
of representation and and represent this
G as a product of a cyclic group of
order a light EEI and and this makes it
more efficient and you can write the
isogen here's a composition of small
degree isogen ease which which then
becomes a new representable so that's
the private it's easy essentially here's
a hard problem on the other hand so
given a curve yi and you want to compute
its anymore simmering to the best of my
knowledge this is still hard and and
this is the the problem you would
ideally like you cryptosystem to rely on
sense is the hardest problem in this
area we focus on the super singer case
so the maximal order is sorry the animal
sibling is maximal ordering in deep
infinity the quaternion algebra ramified
at P and infinity and and what I mean by
this and this is a bit tricky to define
properly but essentially you can you can
return this as this soaring so rank for
ring so you can just return a basis so
four elements and each of those elements
are anamorphisms or they're high degree
maps but you had to return this in kind
of an efficient way as we already
discussed
okay nice thing about this problem is
that it has some histories I mentioned
David Cole back then in 1996 already
studied it and the best dogs we could
come out come out with is exponential
time and that that's essentially still
the best dogs in today
okay so here's is any questions over
here's coil Salafism moref so suppose
that you want to find an Animorph ism
for this curve you fix a small prime
then you look at all neighbors then you
look at all neighbors of neighbors and
all neighbors of neighbors and neighbors
so you're building its tree at some
point you will find a collision so
you're competing all the Jim Burns at
some point there will be 2 J variants
that are equal and you can actually bond
that based on on on the non bonds on the
diameter of those graphs or you can
expect that actually in squares of P
you'll get a collision okay that's a
very simple algorithm when you get a
collision actually you can expose this
vertex and this vertex equal but well
you just take this bus and then you come
back here and that makes a nano morphism
and if you repeat that several times say
four times a bit more you get a sub ring
of the anamorphisms that you could
reasonably expect to be actually the
world range all right so this is nice
but not the fission of course square
root of P is exponential in n log P
another problem in this area is you're
given two curves now easier on e1 and
you want to compute an eye surgeon in
between them okay
so it's kind of similar to the previous
one except that in the previous one
II won any easier or I equal right again
for this problem to be hard the green
must be large so you cannot really
return Phi is a rational not to mention
that this problem is the same kind of
hardest as the previous one we actually
writing a paper on trying to make that
from that claim formal but it's not too
hard to prove
mystically and in encrypter sometimes
you see some some additional conditions
on the degree so if you see want this to
be a decisive genie to be easily
represented also perhaps you will
require to purify to be equal to L to D
so that's also the case in Christian
search engine that doesn't really change
the harness and the complexity of the
part the program can be solved in about
the same complexity square root of P so
you given the two curves easier and ee1
now what you do you build two trees from
e0 anyone until you get a collision
citizenship since you say maxim and and
and you expect to get this collision in
in in roughly this time okay
so roughly the same problem same
complexity any questions so far
great I want to mention this during
correspond so back then in 1931 during
proved that there is a bijection between
super singularity curves over square up
to Galois conjugacy and maximal orders
in the cotton algebra beep infinity up
to conjugation by invertible items and
the correspondence is actually very
simple you just a map e to its
endomorphs in ring okay so essentially
what this says that every super
singularity curve as never seen ring
that is maximal order and and they're in
projection all right under this
correspondence you can translate isogen
E's from e1 to e2 into an ideal from the
corresponding oh one I know to which is
both a left ideal for one and right
ideal for two and the degree five will
become the norm of AI and there's this
kind of dictionary that is that is clear
from a mathematical point of view but
not very explicit and maybe not
efficient to compute and of course we're
working on that
another interesting relevant result in
this area
shouldn't say interesting because it is
my result but relevant say is what has
been called a quaternion as isogen ii
problem more so it's in light of this
correspondence between quaternion m and
elliptic curves one strategy that we
tried with Christine back then 2009
already I think is to try try to try to
translate the hard problems in for her
hash function into problems ricotta new
algebra solve them in a cotton energy
band and translate a solution back to
elliptic curves and with respect to this
strategy was was natural to consider
this problem which is kind of the
equivalent of ISO Genie problems but for
the quaternion algebra ok so to be clear
we were given two maximal orders and the
goal is to find an an an ideal that
connects the two of them which has a
norm in the case of the hash function
wanted L to the e no ok so it's not too
hard to compute an ideal that that
connects all 0 and a 1
but then the trick was actually to
compute another ideal in the same class
that has that had the appropriate node
and this is solved in our is paper as
2014 where we provide a use the Gaussian
that solve this problem with with known
roughly equal to P to the Stonehouse all
right good I'm nearly done with this
kind of introduction
yes sorry here you solve the equivalent
problem in the core training yes yeah so
could you comment on what the problem is
translating it back to the elliptical
yes if it's this one so you're given two
K you're given two curves and you want
to compute in either G you saw
quaternion yeah
so in in terms of translating back if we
could it if we could really solve that
we would solve everything in this area
but we we do have a partial translation
in
case that leads to a collision attack on
Christine sighs function for special
parameters version why does Caesar work
well first of all it's hard to compute
the an immersion ring the point is he's
dating is almost as an equivalent
problem which is the hardest of
computing if any more vibrates it's
really the problem yeah okay so the
translation pack is kind of really the
hard one okay okay so yeah I mentioned
this during correspondence and here I
want to like it just rephrase what
Kristin just said so indeed well if you
given a Jim Vern corresponding the
corresponding computing the
corresponding order so computing these
correspondence if the hard problem so
that's something that you would hope for
crypto is hard because otherwise
everything is broken is there okay on
the other hand if you give it a maximal
order computing the chamber and it's
something that you could call it the
inverse Animorph simmering competition
problem and that's something for which
we now have a heuristic per unit
analysis when I say no actually you
should say here we have had for for six
years but awfully this month the paper
was finally become public yeah so that's
kind of easy so so what you see here is
kind of a one-way function based on on
this during correspondence work and in
one direction you can actually compute
the during correspondence and the other
actually still if their heart and
candidate heart power in for crypto no
no that doesn't help it doesn't help
though as far as I know and I think this
is my life slide in this section
so I mentioned some problems I think our
or heart here's the problem that happens
in that occurs in in in the key exchange
and an encryption and very much protocol
by geography okay so you do have a nice
urgent problem or you give it oops
so you given to Jane Verne's essentially
are two curves
and you want to compute an eye surgeon
between them but first of all because
you want the torsion to be defined over
F P Square you'll require and one and
two the divide key okay that means that
n one and two are kind of small
and also that P is kind of special so in
the parameters I suggest and one is two
to be big and two is treat the big so so
this kind of a person like Prime and in
other context this is not something that
you would like to go for and well as far
as I know this doesn't need to any
weakness but I would be cautious about
it I've already mentioned that right
there P over twelve super single
invariant worse for n1 you just have
roughly square root of in choices so
again that introduces some potential
weakness in fact that makes an attack
more efficient and finally and that
would be relevant for the last part of
this talk there is some extra
information provided remember to
complete a key exchange
I sent Bob back to reveal the image of P
and what for Bob the image of P and Q a
to Phi B okay so essentially as you can
do linear combination they reveal the
image of the wall and a torsion v-fib
okay so this also could potentially
introduce some weakness although prior
to this work I mean nothing was known in
that direction okay so the point two was
kind of known to introduce some weakness
and they chose the parameters according
to that bone one I'm not sure this
actually make an e and anyway this
actually lead to any weakness but that's
something I would I would actually look
later I think it's worth investigating
and now we we coming to that point here
okay any questions so far
okay so an attack on the key exchange
could could solve the following problem
computer neither genie so give an easier
anyone computer nitrogen imaging them of
degree N one given the action of this
isogen e on distortion group okay so
natural question is how useful is this
additional information right well
clearly if if N 1 equal to n 2 then
essentially this action should reveal
the kernel acts also if N 1 is equal to
n 2 this would be very damaging to the
particle and that's why they have this
requirement the GCD of N 1 and n 2 are
co-prime is called 1 and similarly if I
mean if if they're not equal but has a
non-trivial GCD then you also able to
recover part of Phi 1 I guess Lee also
they do require and run into to be
co-prime which is good
another result in this area is the paper
we had with with Steven any student
named Taylor Crips is that if you have
the it's an active attack so so in that
paper what we showed is that in the
context where one of the secret key is
static doesn't change an attacker can
not follow the protocol instead of
sending the right information like Phi
Phi B of B a and Phi P of Q a send from
other points and from this this other
point that you would then eventually
recover the sequence ok so there is this
kind of active attacks were you not
during the protocol and and to several
run of interaction with with with the
other party you actually recover the
secret key but what about passive
attacks
what about attacks that first of all
don't require a lot of interaction and
just maybe observe one round of the
protocol and derive the secret key from
there okay so that's the point of of of
this section
all right so before going into into this
problem I want to kind of warm up and
and consider the potential easier
problem and and hear this
so let's PD a prime and E super
seniority curve of our ft square let's
find the number freedom of non-scalar an
unsparing a morphism of E now I assume
that Phi is smooth order and 1 ok let's
enter the another smooth integers such
that it's co-prime 2 and 1 and let's let
P Q be basic for e of n 2 so we
essentially in a setting of the key
exchange
except that Phi is not neither Jean
between two curves it's an Animorph ism
of one curve okay let's our be a
suffering of this n Emerson ring such
that that is either you need to compute
or given in some way okay so for example
you know the scatter medications right
giving the curve you know that they're
all the sky ramification so so that
could be an example of or in some other
context perhaps the curve is the final
recipe and you and you know both the
scarification and the Frobenius so you
have the walls of suffering generated by
by the Frobenius lens garments creation
okay so this is a totally realistic
assumption and then the program wants
consider here is so given this curve the
the basis for for event to but I could
recompute that but freshly given the
image of 5p and Phi of Q the degree of
Phi and the sub ring compute Phi okay
so again kind of setting of the key
exchange except that it's numer of the
more instead of being a nitrogen so if
you if you look at it from the point of
view of what was known before the best
Azam is is essentially this meeting the
middle strategy
so the an amorphous and is degree N 1 so
you take and then one is smooth so you
could do a like square root of N 1 that
direction square root of N 1 in that
direction and and the total cost is
roughly this and and and then you get an
anniversary all right and with our show
know is a square root improvement attack
so essentially a force root of N 1
attack using crucially the extra
information that is provided by by by
5:00 p.m. 5:00 cue the kind of extra
information that's also provided in a
key exchange protocol all right any
questions so far
ok so let's go for it so we know Phi on
VN 2 version ok so we can deduce also v
height on the into torsion right just
because Phi is Phi times Phi hat is
equal to n 2 and sorry 21 and one is
co-prime to n 2 so we did use Phi hat on
G in the world into torsion okay then we
did use the trace of Phi module and 2
right because it's just Phi plus Phi hat
and and we also know that the trace is
an integer smaller than two squares of N
1 so assuming in 2 is bigger than 2
square root of N 1 which by the way is
the case indication protocol then this
information this information actually
gives you the trace of Phi over the
integers all right let me know if
there's any question all right so now we
will consider this anamorphisms and I
want to stress a Dunlop's I but but I
will be formally a linear combination of
Phi and and scholar integer and
miscommunications ok so Phi so let's let
Abe in V V two integers and let's try B
equal to a 5 plus B I claim that we can
evaluate saionji into torsion ok we know
we don't know upside but nevertheless we
can evaluate it on on the into torsion
right because we know this car
multiplication and we know Phi on the n2
all right so far the first step in the
attack will be to find two integers a
and B such that the degree of Sai that
you can rewrite it in this way forget
about it for now is equal to n - x + 1 -
okay so M 2 is is the integer where you
know where you can evaluate Phi Phi and
what Phi n time and anyone - you want it
to be small and small all right so my
goal here is to find two integers a and
B such that the degree of of psy is
equal to 2 this such that an n1 - is
small and spoon okay and if you look at
this equation degree of psy you can
rewrite it in this form such as side x
sy hat so a squared degree of 5 plus B
squared plus AV trace of file and we
know degree of Phi and now we no trace
of Phi okay so we know everything here
so if a quadratic equation quadratic
defending equation to solve kind of so
this is not given but we want a small a
small solution here okay I'll come back
to how to find nd in the next slide but
to continue so we have the groups I
equal to n - x + 1 - so I can write my
eyes or genie on my endomorphs and Phi
as a composition of two - I so genies
one of the green - and one of the green
one - alright and remember I can
evaluate sy on the Intuit ocean so I can
actually identify the part of the kernel
up side that corresponds to the end -
torsion so I can I can by evaluating sy
on the Intuit ocean I recover the kernel
up sy n 2 and therefore I also did use
tire of n - okay so now I've got
computer decides LG needs - - and I've
reached another curve and I know that
this other curve what's happening oh no
okay
excuse me a second and I know that this
other curve is uh is connected to my
curves via an idea of degree M + 1 -
right where is this I think so no it
doesn't fit here so so so you've you're
covered
cyan - and then and then for the last
part for this part as soon as as long as
n1 - its moves and small enough then you
can just apply this meeting the middle
strategy okay so so what actually we
show in the paper is that I can hope to
have n1 - roughly square root of n 1 and
that leads to the square root of
improvement as I was talking about so
once you you get - 1 - you're not
entirely done so what you do is well
essentially you have give an expression
website and you can now evaluate this
expression subside on the n1 portion and
therefore you can you can evaluate sy
minus B over a on the n1 torsions
recover the kernel of of Phi and deduce
Phi and you don't any questions so far
no ok so the only thing that remains is
this part right so so we have an
equation of this form where degree is
known the trace is known and 2 is fixed
and I want to find a and B such that + 1
- 2 small as soon as possible
okay okay so the paper I solve that by
looking at the equation module and -
okay so modular into a set of solution
form a two-dimensional lattice okay
and this is a quadratic form
corresponding to the two dimensional
lattice so so you can compute this
lattice you can compute a short basis
for this lattice and then you can run
some kind of exhaustive search among a
small linear combination of these small
bases until you hit a vector that has a
norm a short Nome such that n one - and
one - is smooth enough okay
you have to kind of balance start there
but but what we argue in the paper is
that you can expect that n 1 - will be a
smaller square root of N 1 by kind of
goshen heuristic argument a square root
of n 1 yeah and and that's it ok so what
this shows is that in this particular
program which is a bit similar to the
key exchange when you reveal the image
of a large torsion group this is not
innocent right this actually leads to a
near square root speed up to to the
problem what some parameter restriction
applies I think never does it suggest
any questions so far
yeah it's a two-dimensional lattice so
so you can its Euclid algorithm pretty
efficient the stuff that is not very
efficient is to find a short element in
this slice right so no oh sure no sorry
I show the reminiscing but finding an
element search that n1 - it's gonna be
smooth so you expect and one - to be for
the smallest vector to be roughly square
root of n 1 and then you also want it to
be smooth in order and and so if you if
you if you expect that
elements in the lattice have known that
are distributed like random numbers and
if you if you pay us a big financial
price to get norms that are subjects
financial size such that n1 - its
subjects women shallowly smooth then you
get the square root speed-up roughy okay
but there are also the freight of where
you can just do a little more a little
oh okay I didn't plug it you can do a
little you can do a little bit less work
on on finding short vectors and then you
have to do a little more work on on this
meet in the middle a strange thank you
any questions so far
great so if you guys in Part B are
purchasing interested in the key
exchange protocol oh I thought I'd with
mu class
well it's okay essentially it's an open
problem in the paper but it I think it's
nice also I want to do a move it the
case of just food to see word about it
the case of where the curve is defined
over SB so now you know a bit more than
just a scalar medication and and you
could hope that well this equation here
you could hope that n1 - you can choose
any one - a bit smaller the way I think
what kind of idea we have to solve it
actually doesn't involve solving this
equation but but I think there should be
a point even time I wasn't in this case
anyway yeah okay so this is what you
will be interested in now we're back to
the kind of key exchange setting so let
ki be a prime and wanting to the two
co-prime integers easier super seniority
over Fisk where F is neither Geneva team
easier anyone of the green one I assume
that I know two sub ranks of both easier
anyone of both the Animorphs in ring of
easy right anyone
and well whereas in the previous attack
I could just use the scale variations
also as general I guess you'd you you
would like here to assume a bit more
about er0 so if r0 is just a scar
medication at the moment I I haven't
found a way to make this techniques work
so I need to assume that I know they
didn't bit more than that but but you'll
see it it makes sense in some settings
and the problem here is so given all
those parameters and given the image of
Phi on the wall and to torsion compute
Phi okay so kind of a key exchange
setting and again if you if you don't
use this this information at all like
people live in their provision arises
then the best outcome is kind of meet in
the middle and that that's called square
root of N 1 okay so interesting to see
whether those techniques can actually
lead to interesting speed-up in that
case as well all right maybe I should
say a word about this assumption here so
in in some implementation work including
by Microsoft people the curve easier
institution as J equal to 1 728 for
efficiency reason and in that case you
don't just know discovery situation that
you actually know the wall and Emerson
ring ok so so the assumption is is
realistic in that sense okay any
questions so far
general ID let's fit a be an element in
Indiana Merson ring of easier
there is non-scalar sorry should have
written that so we consider the an
Animorph some of v1 given by the
composition of C one-half v1 hut theta
and c1 ok I don't I don't know this
right that's about what I want to
compute but I I know the I can evaluate
Phi 1 on the and to torsion and I know
theta so even though I don't know fire
can actually evaluate you on the into
the ocean by what is given in the
problem okay and then I have an animal
freedom of e1 where I know it's image on
a big tour group and I can apply to
picnics from the previous section of
this okay once I've done that that kind
of recover spy but Phi is not what I
want I want five five one right so to
compute Phi one I kind of intersect the
kernel Phi with with the eat and one
version this gives me more or less the
kernel of Phi 1 - five by one hash hat
sorry and then I compute Phi 1 hat and
then I use Phi 1 as well and I'm done
right I've kind of hidden from some
aspects here there are conditions from
the parameters and two has to be big
enough compared to and one for this to
work you try I'll come to death now a
little bit more detail but the intuition
is I mean the general idea is here in
this slide so a couple of remark so
several tours growing people sitting
there have been I've been using J equal
to 1028 just because that makes
computation more efficient okay so in
that case not only you have it's a bring
of easier of an anniversary of the year
but you know it entirely not only you
know it entirely but also there are
small elements in this one right there
is a degree one non-scalar element
Indiana of the ring and both aspect the
fact that you know the world animal
swimming and the fact that they're small
elements are useful in this thing for
these techniques okay so in the paper
what we do is we developed two attacks
that follow kind of those lines but I
don't think that this is the end of the
story so what I already mentioned some
improvements come and
and I expect more to come alright so
just to say a few word about about this
so if you take easier equal to 1028 and
if you have this parameter so n1 roughly
the size of P Square which is what you
would like if you want the two curves to
be a uniform e what you if you want the
the second curve to be uniformly
distributed you would actually need and
one to be roughly equal to P Square so
that's what you would like but also for
the attack to work you need them to be a
bit bigger than that okay those are the
two condition for for this effective
work but then that goes to condition you
actually get per ml ten key recovery
okay
following those lines another variant
that we develop is only assuming that
this guy is a small element so I don't
necessarily require to know all of it
but just I needed to have a small
element and I'm given a bit less
information so I have to be a bit I have
to require a bit more from from from
that side so the requirement here is
that log n 2 is roughly square root of
log N 1 so I'd say the balance between n
2 and N 1 is is quite different I tend
to this is quite significantly bigger
than N 1 in this case
this gives just four times as large in
size then in this setting another we
develop another attack it's more it's a
variant of the above strategy so
recursive recursive attack where we take
the problem and then we use it to
another problem the same nature but
smaller parameters and and this leads to
again appointment time key recovery
attack as I said already I don't think
this is the end of the story I mean you
could you could obviously balance
parameters differently if you are not
just interested in putting the time key
recovery but
just want to look at maybe some still
exponential but more efficient in
previous key features so I think there's
still a lot of work to be done in that
direction on the other hand to the best
of my knowledge of course I tried a bit
if you pick the parameters I suggested
in the field job newspaper there you
have anyone into roughly equal and and I
haven't been able to to develop an
attack following those lines yet okay
but it's plausible that it will come in
question so far
yes middle ground here is four times
larger than this value equal nothing
happens like what a bit Slater side yeah
you would you expect through those
anyways and with the size of these n1 n2
so then I'm guessing that you need these
columns not irrational over at least
with I well oh yeah yeah what not the
eye surgeon is always over eighty square
but the subgroups the torsion might be
defined very interesting but the I so
genies are always defined I mean can for
super similar curves you can always
define the other genes by fiscal so this
this attack only applies to kind of my
variant if you like your words this one
applies to both assuming that I mean
there's there's one reason you might
want unbalanced parameters so suppose
you're in a setting where were one key
static and corresponds to a server price
then you would like to put more security
on the static key okay so in that case
it would make sense to have and to
bigger than n1 process or get rerun so
so I think I phrase it in the abstract
as this leads to attacking of variants
in a plausible attack scenario and I
think that's an accurate description not
it's not it doesn't yet break the key
exchange protocol for the parameters
suggested but but watch out for for
further results and and and if if this
paper hasn't come I would have been
plausible brought that somebody would
have try and balance parameters put more
security on the study key right I'm glad
you don't disagree on that okay any
questions so far
okay so it's conclude what we can build
some cool crypto based on either game
problems and recycle a curve
cryptography in a in a post Contin world
which is kind of cool
there there progress and I think they
are very interesting but betting or I
wouldn't I wouldn't put national
security and I'm relying on that right I
mean it needs first study even though I
think the situation is better than other
problems that are currently suggested
for for post condom security in the
sense that is had been studied before it
was suggested for crypto at least if if
if you really focus on the anniversary
competition problem and go for variants
like in the key exchange but never do
this I mean it's interesting problems
they do require definitely more are more
welcome catalysis before we trust them
but I'm I hope there will be a
submission to NIST because I would
motivate more work in that direction
Radian and who knows so if in 10 years
time this attacks are still the best
attacks then it makes sense to actually
put some valuable that I in the hands of
those problems and then last point I
want to make is is this one which i
think is this i wouldn't face a shock to
people but but certainly wasn't it
wasn't known before
personally I think it's kind of natural
righty you you
problem were you why reveal additional
information of course this information
wasn't used before but it was always
kind of natural that it was a potential
weakness in the protocol and and and the
Argos my presented go in that direction
all right any question yes would you use
for no I wouldn't
I think all of them me more more study
and night and even lattices I mean the
for parameter suggested I don't think
that has been magic applying this work
and I think I think this I hope I really
hope there would be a submission in that
because that would multi get more work
as well I don't know he planning to make
one yes
great will you use J equal to one 728
maybe that's true
they actually have mentioned that if you
are it's not known how to generate a
random super singer chamber and if not
by taking a special curve and then
making random walk so you could do that
but then those attacks kind of there's a
risk that they come back in kind of a
backdoor way right one still was the
wall yeah yeah so so in a sense of a
impact maybe even bigger but yeah I
wouldn't recommend using vehicle to
special jato but yeah but on the other
hand you will pay a price efficiency or
in the in the setup issued on or just I
mean if there's a reasonable way to come
up with a different jail where someone
doesn't know the walks with a Jake with
72h oh yeah I thought about it having
fun anything
why do you do see em together to get an
on-site okay
then he is he a nice efficient but that
means the discriminate small and then
you can you can you can find a small
degree I so Jimmy and the Mersenne so
essentially the same selling so I have
yeah I don't see any way around it but
you'll be using J equal to the issuance
addition if you care about efficiency
more than secure yeah so how did the
confirm I'm curious so how do you
compare it to how would you compare it
in terms of efficiency with other
kernels how will you sell it like white
is the best one I mean just a different
problem high-end is a small small kids
let's pretend we had the smallest keys
mhm
slow it's probably it's a slow song I
also come at you orders online Jen
really well so how fast is it and how
long did it take to make occasion wrong
for us well they need a sales model
he usually notice it on your birthday
level you the benefit application
wouldn't be a problem so that's one it's
interesting also people like latex got
something made yeah yeah it's kind of
change anymore she's good to me
thank you
[Applause]